yeah thanks was a nice infection and
welcome to the session about NLP and
particular transfer learning NLP right
now it's really exciting time to work in
Anarchy but it's also developing in such
an incredible pace that sometimes we
could keep on track with the latest
developments so I hope this session
today will help you to get a bit up to
speed with transfer learning NLP latest
language models that actually use for
that and also show you this how to use
those models in your daily work in my
daily work
I actually deal with both sides Bernanke
on the one hand side research and on the
other hand side the industry in research
he stays up here ever says a lot about
transfer learning or conferences uh
basically flooded with papers around
that topic we see new language models
basically of weekly base and also
there's new state of the art
performances published for downstream
tasks like question answering or
semester languages on the other hand
with the industry and they have quite
some different requirements when it
comes to appeal he it's just deploying
at scale different data different domain
language so there's quite a gap between
those two sides and my daily job I
basically try to bridge that gap from
industry to research and that's why two
years ago we found that you said small
start-up in Berlin where we try to do
exactly that and we do that basically
three different approaches on the one
hand side we have almost all software
models that we publish free for
everybody to use free for developers and
then we talk about that some enterprise
features
e 21 Detroit scale and we do some custom
development on something I'm not sure
what's happening with the screen but
we'll be back soon
all right so that's my little job for
today I would like to UM go this through
transfer and to explain the major
concept behind it then look at one core
component of transfer learning the
language model itself and different
variants of it then going over to some
education
tonsillitis quacks I love these days
question answering because there we
really see the biggest improvements and
then finally the son of a little naughty
so what R stands for learning it here
basically here is pretty simple and I
think also yesterday they've already
quite some talks about it it's basically
you take one huge data set train what
about that and this model requires some
kind of mother to that's it and this
knowledge you will then transfer to a
different task to different model and by
doing that you actually need that way
more to a smaller data set for your
second task so the model not only learns
from the second data set but also has
some case are basically with some prior
knowledge that's the best idea
the advantage of that is mostly to meet
less labels for your tasks and you get a
better performance this is I would say
pretty much the sweet dream of every
machining engineer better performance
with less labels and also labels lot of
applications in the industry to other
advances that are not mentioned that
often but for me quite important um yes
also has a big implication on your
development cycle engine development
style we experiences really accelerates
your development work it's just pasta
and on the other engines gets more
standardized and lets you reuse a lot of
components across projects across
different tasks in your company which
which helps a lot to leave these silos
in general is not new at all it has been
around in computer vision for years so I
guess some of you come from this year
and know that there was English met I
think published in 2011-12 around that
huge collection of images annotated with
objects and people use their to train
the model this model learned some basic
knowledge reputation marks is geometry
some textures and this model was then
able to transfer it downstream tasks to
other applications for example finding
two screws in in the industry quite
boring tasks but that's many tasks in
the industry so people also tried that
we repeat and it didn't really work for
a long time and what people try to do is
also putting in a large text corpora for
example you pedia and do some kind of
model and these models usually also
learn some kind of impressive knowledge
some general understanding of language
it's been hard to visualize this
knowledge it's usually some kind of word
embedding some synonyms that get similar
vectors in space
something about subjects they learn in
this motion can be transferred to
another class for example in the
industry classifying legal contracts and
people tried that but never really was
not working a similar scale like well
the good news now is it's working
finally and I think this is only happens
within the last year and this is
exciting and yeah pretty much yeah
oh and November December last year there
was no model published but which
basically really kicked off stream of
development
research technique this accelerating
this transfer of extreme energy and
since this like only this last year it
had a big impact on a lot of different
areas of energy first for research right
now these kind of models are dominating
all or mostly all leaderboards one that
I'm excited about
squat step for question answering data
set for the task of question answering
and we see here is basically the
timeline and performance at once work
and will receive one year ago there was
a bump and this bump was due to the sky
I've hurt a model of touched by a cougar
which is common not quite now they used
to the most prominent example but it's
not only that's not only used in and
research there's also a lot of
implications in industry a few weeks ago
were announced that they are not using
it for 10 percent of their surgeries in
the US and repeal of such stable that it
was the biggest positive change within
the last five years and this cost a lot
of headlines I was very surprised and we
can't read the newspapers and I saw an
AP bird on the front page of some
generic Germany newspaper and it really
told me ok this is not making the step
into the industry it's not only research
it's not only stuff that you read in
newsletters from this bastard Runa but
it's really getting out there and
actually years ago we're not there also
rolling it off for seventy other
languages so it's not only in the u.s.
anymore
what are some a couple years that we
know but at what scale you have to
imagine millions of search queries and
if you months ago ever said yeah you
know
ok there's power there Spencer learning
but yeah there is transformable is yes
which impractical for my use case
Google's not shortened that you can do
it if you want and if it's if there's
business value for you and they all did
that within one year last time only
Easton support also has big implications
on style of work for us as machinima
engineer so they are scientists I think
the last years they pretty much felt
like crazy right
the ladies soap boxes you try to you
look for the best model for your
particular task engineer here future
engineer here additional layers and in
the end you had something that worked it
was super fun you basically won this
race maybe that wasn't really
sustainable and I think this is not
changing we go from these individual
models individual silos for each
particular task to a more standardized
way of trying in a key of training
models and I think this is it's pretty
much subscribe by building on the
shoulders of giants so you take these
big three trend models and apply it or
fine-tune it for your particular domain
and this changes the whole style of
working also more an operational level
we focus on our team experience that we
basically completely Chester's
development from local machines to
remote interpreters in the cloud having
GPUs so not only using GPUs anymore for
only for training but also in
development using that as tremors are
because these models are super big and
just typical to whatever CPU and
so how exactly is Franz gonna be now
performed in anarchy what different
phases do we have there there are
different styles of transferring but
most of the time right now as we talk
about it it's sequential transferring
and sequential transfer learning has
three phases first one basically taking
every text corpus and training a
language model from scratch on the
surface the second phase is an optional
face if you work in some domain where
the language is a bit more specific for
example in biomedicine or in some
technical engineering environment then
you might want to adapt this language
model to a certain to make course
so basically new training for a
particular domain in the third and last
phase in transfer learning isn't
actually applying your model to a
downstream task so basically the task
that you're really interested in this
might give a named entity recognition
document classification question
answering search forever so these
language models are really the core
component in this transfer learning
paradigm so let's have a look into what
the edge they are called the idea of
egis ones are pretty straightforward you
have a sentence and you mask out a
certain word and if you read human the
sentence you already think automatically
what is the word missing here in the
middle the fox over the street and you
already come up with ideas about this
and it might be the Fox runs over the
speed walks over the street jumps
whatsoever
and this task seems very simple but
let's actually use super-powerful in the
finale world and the reason for that is
that you need really to understand
context to master this task and
understanding context means that you
need on the one hand side the subtext
but also semantics you need to
understand what this sentence is
in perspective but also the subtext is
important in this example for example T
the runs with an S in English you need
to write communication right for the
last bhisma it's powerful but it's
widely used it's very cheap to train or
to create training data you don't need
any humans to annotate your examples you
can just fill in any text and
automatically create examples by
blinking of words so that's super
powerful I think in every youth most
every model out there is probably used
so that's a quick look someday these
names models can on the one side be used
for generating language on the other
hand site for understanding language
right now let's try to generate some
text for that there's a website called
Fox transformers which is basically
deploying one of the most prominent
models out there gp2 it's running not
the biggest models not the most powerful
one but rather small version of it but
it's I think enough for for playground
with it is rather water fast
so yeah that's maybe try to fit in some
text let's maybe say
ages against so from against from the
restart support and let's see what
language model does with that there is
opponent that much Italy to bid next
family from water and spawned by Elton
travelers looking for country that can
help them spread their whatever richer
and so on and so on
and so what happening here is basically
that model one word after the other
samples and predicts what comes next
and it was didn't think about this is
now that these recent models really
managed to keep the context over quite
some some long sequence so it means that
you really can create stories that makes
some kind of sense often they also push
up to the others but at least they are
chromatically correct and they pick up
the initial idea also after a few
sentences anybody else with the sentence
that he wants to try okay then yeah
maybe you want to play around with at
home it's fun they're different variants
so these neighbors ones can get one
inside just be used for generating
languages we saw but more often they
actually used for understanding language
for these downstream tasks like entity
recognition and one very prominent model
out there I already mentioned it but
released one year ago by Google and it
was basically trained on a pre trade
with two objectives to tastin the
beginning the one is the master language
model so just what we saw and the second
one is next sentence prediction we will
see that in a minute
it was trained on about thirty gigabyte
of data using Wikipedia and some public
available books so let's now go through
each of these three phases pre-training
domain adaptation downstream and see
what what actually is done in these
phases and I also tried to give some
tips and recommendations that we found
useful working with these kind of models
in the last year so when you try to
scratch you basically fit in a pair of
sentences so one here and one here you
must add some words and you feel them to
the mode architecture what about that we
have two different prediction has one
focus to an acceptance prediction and
the other one on language modeling and
this is an acceptance prediction
basically tells you only to predict if
these sentences come one after the other
in the original document or not in this
case
probably not they go together and
language model fills in the blanks as we
just saw if you want to really train
such a model from scratch what what when
is it useful I would say in from the 80%
of the cases it's not useful it's only
useful if your child language is very
different from the ones that are already
published so this model for English
there's a really trained model for
German and I think no there's no model
for Polish so this would make sense
Porter's one it also in some domains
where you main language is super
different then might make sense of
gender special it only makes sense if
you have roughly about thinking about of
text data I will say in in your new
application it really means having small
performance gains and from the modeling
side translates to big business value so
if you start off here just a small case
might not make sense that if you are in
a corporate with many application of
that also one percent performance a lot
if you do it I would recommend to train
with smaller base model first so they
always that means you smaller model and
then the Juche ones you which ones tend
to converge more strangely or we saw
difficult parents they're the smaller
ones are nicer and better to start with
and then this these ones are usually
quite robust in terms of parameters one
Singh the premier that is not robust is
the learning rate so keep that really in
mind this so usually instead of super
start with some smaller learning rate
and then pump it up so everybody rate
schedules for example this is and then
one trick that is actually have to
define a maximum sequence length that
you feed in into the smaller and the
longer sequence length us the more
computation you need in this model it's
actually credit quite wrenches
so what helps is that during the
training from scratch do 90% of the
training action quite small sequence
length quite fast and then only last 10%
you do want a really low sequencing this
is enough for the module also to you
with the longer ones and it has to go
from weeks of retraining down to a few
days
so now we have a pre-trained language
model and the second phase is then if
you are working some domain adapted to
this particular language that you have
and what you do there is basically
continuing the same style of training
that we saw before the changes what you
feed you feed now in not in the EPI text
anymore for example some some either
text from contracts and this is useful
if you are working in a domain with some
particular patterns particular
variations in my experience actually it
is the case than most companies maybe
news is a bit different but for all
others I've seen there's usually some
specifics in the domain and this face is
already helpful if you have roughly
about five megabytes of text data also
case with twelve megabytes worth some
seduced so it's worth in most cases it
also helps but it's useful if for your
final downstream training you only have
very few training centers so in contrast
let's say us downstream tasks document
education and you have 10 million
imitated examples then this space
doesn't make sense for you because the
stall Street ask the model they already
have enough time to adapt to this domain
and all the specifics then you don't
need this I can use that if you do this
again lower rate stop there try to come
up as someone what should also do here
is modified vocabulary so for example
the standards Berg has around 30,000
focus of the open and there are 3,000
unused focus basically place orders and
it doesn't exchange those placeholders
with your own terms
that come up in the language many
companies that's product names every
ations
and so on but also help them make it for
today to be conducted is experimenting
with additional tasks so we have here
this next sentence task and language
modeling but in some domains you also
have access to additional meta
information so for example what kind of
contract this sentence comes from and
you can be a some classification as a
third task this also helps to learn more
about the to make that way so if you've
done all that we we are not in the final
phase downstream so you will really see
them the fruits of your work where you
can have them and they are one example
exemplary daunting task might be
classification so now you mister take
this but more from the previous steps
but you remove the relations heads that
we saw before and put instead of
classification head this is just if you
want to send the layers new network and
it's very cheap to add this and then you
can actually predict what topics the
sentence for example is about these
relation heads are really something like
a swiss knife you can exchange easily
now what tasks you want to apply this
module you can put here an entity
recognition question answering you name
it basically a few tasks so this was not
all about birds and I think it's still
one of the most popular central models
that you have out there but as I said
beginning the Spiritist developing at an
incredible pace and there are new
language models out there every week and
some days I think it's not important to
understand all of them but it's quite
helpful to see what kind of trends are
there what are the next language models
about so let me put a few of them up
here there was a while ago a model
called Stanford and but the office tip
there is actually changing the objective
of the latest model from only masking
single focus to actually masking full
stem so multiple talks and that was
quite interesting
then there was Roberta published by
Facebook and what they basically did is
they took more data train for longer
time using a lot of exercise and they
also got rid of the next sentence
prediction and also that one moose about
performance quite quite a lot so I think
there's also some general pattern for
these kind of models more data usually
helps and then they recently Google
publish advert which is dominating
benchmarks both leaderboards and they
had also some interesting ideas how to
go on with these architectures for
vision change and what they do is
basically they make this model more
efficient by sharing ways across
different layers different transformers
and they vectorized in varies so
basically in beginning there's say with
vocabulary of 30,000 tokens you would
have a metrics of 30,000 times your very
dimensionality and this vectorization
Basin reduce that to a few matrix
multiplications that are way cheaper in
terms of memory and they also very this
is an acceptance prediction of it so we
already see a pattern the solution X
temptation of birth is probably not the
future there's a lot of experiments to
change that the last Direction
wallet-sized so these models are quite
huge they believe is are trained on GPUs
and now there are a lot of attempts to
bring them down so they actually run
them on even mobile devices and Tomales
there Cubert is papered they believe so
small that you can run them on TV so you
know mobile and they still have around
90% of performance of the original
models that's not more yes way more I
won't know goes for these details I will
share the slides of course and maybe if
you look for a language model in
particular task this might be a good
starting point one topic that's strikes
me quite a lot is that most of these
language models are focusing on English
language so what about non-english
languages what about polish what about
German there are these multilingual
models but they are always working well
for for your particular language so yes
you said try to promote also these
language models in other languages we
trained in open source the German one
we're currently training showing advert
and we have some collaboration with
Google so if you were interested in for
example finding a modern your language
polish maybe please approach me when it
is bothered with knowledge code and also
with TPU session in the new book so now
we know more about this language models
what can you do with them let's focus on
possible magnification called question
answer and I think it's best explained
again with the demo what is question
answering
once at this table again is perfect if
you want to play around with this
justice website and it's all the sauce
so we can even deploy this by easily
with a block on the own infrastructure
replace which all models in here
whatever you like so in
question-answering you basically have to
push it in one passage or one document
and then we can ask questions that might
be answer from this document and we have
some examples up here but I really
prefer it'll trust these these examples
so let's let's try something different
with you today this is Center so let's
take the wiki article from Las Vegas we
just paste this may be few passages here
and now we can start asking questions so
what do you want to know about cocaine
cause maybe what did
and then one of the basically schedule
text and tries to identify spam that
answers this question and we find that
Copernicus formulates the model of the
universe that placed the Sun rather than
earth at the center of the universe
quite I would say so let's try something
else when did he die so also here the
monk basically identifies this date as
the date of death but the work is not
met but not mentioned at all and this is
something important that has changed now
similar question-answer systems work
before but they always relied on Reese
keyword matching or very similar words
giving this context and this is no
different with these innocent later
models you can also ask of course where
did you live
in oil pressure and what is that and
what is
basically if that had been part of the
kingdom of Poland since 1466 so you see
this you can the uses twigs basic
diversity into text and that's how in
this is right now only on a small
passage what we do know in projects is
actually doing that on large scale
having thousands of documents which
other space in the backdrops and having
them basically tool dashboard for people
where they can type in and analyze
documents and other centers or sauce so
someone has a bonus question answering
basically question message and you
extract and answer all of that that's
what we also call extractive
question-answering there's also other
variants that are quite interesting
right now
we have for example one here binary
answers yes or no or you want to
generate a question that generate
answers so you don't need to have the
answers written anymore in the text
itself there's also multiple QA which is
sometimes the answers in different
locations of the document and you need
to aggregate those piece of information
to actually come up with the final
answer and this is all super hot right
now or conferences basically focusing on
that and there's a lot of applications
so let's look a bit under the hood I
don't have time to go into details
unfortunately but I think as engineers
you are usually interested also and what
are they not only be you Iowa vacations
um as you see before we have the model
it's for example take a language model
and now we've hidden text but what we
feed them out here is the question some
separation and then the extra message
both at one time and what we get that
all of this language model is basically
a contextualized
potentialized totally embedding so for
each talking down here
we get a vector we feed these specters
to our prediction hat for question
answering and this question answering
hat them predicts which one is the star
token of the answer and the end roll and
this gives us an Indian T final spam
that we convert back to to speak space
and what is happening on this question
answering had as I said there's vectors
for token going into this prediction
head and then it's only a very channel
feed-forward Network basically has one
input layer and output layer neurons and
these two euros give us launches
probability for the this open right now
is the start of the answer or the end of
the answer and we basically run this
feed forward Network for for each of the
token embeddings who gets the start and
end logics for of the store and we
applied for the receivers and this gives
us then in the end overview of this
world message of the sequence and we
pick the token with the highest start
budget and the one with the highest end
rogers combine them to there's one extra
told what specialty I would say many
cases it's helpful if the model has also
the option to say there is no answer in
the text and this is why I keep it as a
good extra form in the beginning so the
modeling also predates there's no
information news text I cannot answer it
and that's pretty much what happens on
the modeling side so also there if you
look into it it's really really simple
and there's thousands of things that you
can improve and that's what makes you
really excited about this field because
there's
so how can you know implement that
luckily because it is very well a lot of
code established and a lot of frameworks
out there I only will highlight a few of
them right now there's more one my thing
that's very popular these days is
transformers from one phase and what
they do is basically providing the very
last collection of of models so it can
be quite sure if there's a new
complication it will be implemented in
this library they're both white watch
and tensorflow and they have quite some
large research beauty so if you want to
you focus on the modeling side just take
this clay model out there this is a
definite recommendation um we also
started using happy face
basically what yeah go and contributors
or source community develop some
features after what we saw in for really
providing transfer in the industry we
needed a few more features and that's
why we decided to create an own
framework called farm also sauce and
there or focus is really taking these
transformer models we have a face but
providing some additional utility laptop
that is more scalable it's faster it's
easier to keep back and it gives you I
think most flexibility to actually get a
very fast proof of concepts in the
industry and then also bring them into
production and then on top of that right
now we are really excited about QA
question answering that's why we're just
think two weeks ago three weeks ago
produce medicinal framework haystack
which we don't use to do this question
answering and scale so not honest
anymore that thousands of documents if
you're interested check it out it's all
computer also I think sometimes if you
maybe Hammond's use these kind of models
yet it might be use it's intimidating
but it's actually mokou perspective
right now pretty simple and here's one
example how to train a question
answering model it's basically these few
lines of code some data processing
before for data sets the modeling bit
and then the training bit there's also a
collab notebook here how to cook you a
question answering and there's tons of
tutorials father frameworks as well so
let's summarize key statement for say
from my site transfer learning is
working and is that it was look for the
project if you want to keep its right
now changing a lot research industry but
also started working a particular
question answering and see cement into
tasks like summarization they make
incredible progress and this gives of
course exciting opportunities for for
the industry safe service websites I
imagine in the future that also no
documents we don't want anymore for
search or maybe confer queue for answer
questions and the particularly intense
domains science finance so what is ahead
I think next steps are probably that
we'll see more grounds model efficiency
instability so really scale it down
those models while keeping with the
forms something you super excited and
would help to scale in production they
are sort of interesting ideas for new
strategies in transfer learning
I can recommend this paper t54 cougar
the edges to every enemy task to convert
it into a text to text task so if
there's some text and you get awesome
text even for classifications in yard
and this have costs then really like
like one more rule them all and I think
it quite interesting direction generated
to aim and then in the end of the road I
think right now these most of these
models all of this was actually quite
parametric very efficient powerful
dimension and some of you might know the
smoke from debut camera thinking fast
thinking slow well it describes
basically human thinking and he
differentiates between fading fast and
thinking slow just one system to making
fastest all automated pet I mentioned
behavior if you drive from the highway
of the why do you think that all project
work anymore
well the other hand system 2 thinking
fastest really reasoning thinking slowly
or Consequences putting together some
puzzle pieces and this is missing
totally right now yes right now
Europe's some scamming panels around
this topic and it's there's more and why
yes but I think it's very sad
so if you ask me would have asked me say
five years ago if that what we have
today is a I these questions are three
models I probably would have stay that
at least it's a good step in this
direction if you ask me today and I
would say no this is not not a I and
this is what some people these days most
artists the EFA my effect stay a is
whatever hasn't been done yet and I see
every time you figure out how something
works it stops the America say okay yeah
maybe the pharmacist AI
that Indians aliments they were
different the end this is only metrics
notifications right
so I approve the HPAI interesting that's
it for my site thanks for we have time
for questions like one or two questions
tomorrow
yeah question here yeah thank you for
the talk about the question answering
systems I assume it requires annotated
data right the question answering
require annotated data so realistically
how much data do you need to build a
system okay thank you all right one more
back
thank you for the talk I wonder if you
have any experience with cases where the
answer for a question might appear
multiple times within the passage like
in cases where you know you take a very
long one and it might appear more than
once
same answer for the for this question
presented you can of course which are
the top k answers of the document and
then it's up to you what you want to do
with that in some cases we are financial
analysts what do you analyze companies
and then we just return I think the top
five answers and present them also to be
using games and that's all then they can
also still decide what is correct answer
all right one more if dots you can
probably find Malta over lunch or during
the coffee breaks yeah thank you so much
Marta
[Applause]